hello YouTube I am a material if comes
I'm from the world economy forms media
team here's my badge that we all wearing
here in Davos and I help the YouTube
guys to set up this amazing experiments
the Davos question that you were so many
to answer so I mean we have for 300
videos that we received and basically
the participants here answer to your
question so I'd like to say a big thank
you to the entire YouTube community
whenever I think things up here the
annual meeting is over the Google boys
are back on the plane as we speak to
California and now I want to answer that
that was question there was an amazing
session here this morning the sunday
with Benjamin Zander the conductor of
the Boston Philharmonic he was making
the entire audience all the seals sing
the ode to joy that video you can
actually see it here on YouTube on the
World Economic Forum channel just type
youtube.com slash world economic forum
and here I go with my my answer to the
Dallas question here's a song sheet that
we distributed to all the participants
they just had to read it off being
German myself I don't need this saucing
it's in German fighter sure na guitar
funkin tossed our house Elysium via Burt
Aten for your Chunkin English dying
Hylas tomb dinettes Alba binden vida the
steam older Stenger tired I'll mention
the Edinburgh for dines unstuff lu gave
ID so that was my answer to the Davos
question the discussion the dialogue
will continue so stay tuned to YouTube
thank you